eh bien monsieur marche
je suis heureux que finalement les
carpentier et organismes ce que fait
encore un monopole toujours la défense
des monopoles l'injs cantine et rob
kazinsky manche les françaises et les
français jean pierre chevreau gens
m'écoutaient je m'excuse monsieur le
chef du gouvernement provisoire mais
c'est ainsi c'est un scanner le ciel va
ça fait des mois que je cours après ce
débat on invite le leader de
l'opposition passait pas mitterrand
témoin à la télévision tous les années
bissextiles et quand j'arrive en dit de
me taire
alors qu'en fait ce qui cause leurs
représentants des travailleurs et des
bras ce formulaire je suis morte je vous
en mets jumeau tout bientôt vous serrer
la main mais il n'en est pas question
même si elle croit que le jet ski vous
me laissez pas terminée j'aimerais vous
serrez la main car fine on le monde vous
vous posez
comme étant notre meilleur allié
monsieur marché oui je le dis si vous
êtes le leader de la désunion de la
gauche ça c'est peut-être pas la peine
de le crier sur les toits
j'ai fait la cuisine électorale interne
la télé v ni a coûté monsieur marche
j'ai ici eu toute une série d'articles
journée 15 kg qui m'attendent encore et
je m'aperçois que françois mitterrand et
vous d'après vos déclarations connu vous
n'êtes qu'un et abel les premiers frères
g28 monsieur alors écoutez monsieur bah
je vais vous dire quand j'ai vu monsieur
giscard d'estaing vous présenter aux
travailleurs et aux smicards exploités
sur les marches de l'elysée
on savait qu'ils s'étaient laurel et qui
s'était arrimé sera à passer quand les
sept ans belle et qu'apparaissent vous
avez raison monsieur marché ne saurait
peut-être au pendant votre tueur mais
vous n'allez tout de même pas critiquer
mon physique
oh non je m'en garderais rubio parce que
moi je suis comme je suis monsieur le
premier ministre je ne devrais pas les
travailleurs j'irai jamais en
consultation chez un chirurgien
et vous avez raison monsieur manche ça
vous évitera une grosse dépense courrier
- côté les travailleurs à pression et
travailler je marchais d'abord il ya une
chose que très énervante fille dans le
bourg on sait que vous parlez sans arrêt
les travailleurs et mais ceci ne parlait
de travail aux pêcheurs mais écouter
mais moi j'ai alors et messier mais
alors elle s'est inscrite à remercier le
crois mais c'est un s'est astreint dans
la france ya clé travaillèrent vous êtes
le chef du gouvernement voulait pas
qu'on parle de travail et amédée kiseka
va causer alors tu sais qui sont les
travailleurs les travailleurs mais silva
prenez dans des notes là ils sont dans
le noir de la hausse des prix et des
chômages messier bas monsieur marché
vous parlez du noir je pourrais vous
parler du rouge ce serait comme
dostoïevski que vous connaissez j'espère
oui mais c'est pas parce que vous avez
lu les auteurs polonais qu'il faut nous
donner des leçons de culturel park ainsi
car resto farouchement choix il
s'agirait convaincre d'entrer dans ce
débat notre bon et bien leur dites donc
et vous êtes but qui êtes vous mais ce
n'est pas le meilleur économiste de
france
oui ça c'est la belle giscard d'estaing
mais qui dort à voter pour vos élections
monsieur marché la majorité des français
je vous le dis en passant oui alors
évidemment c'est possible mais si vous
choisissez le triangle j'ai fait une
enquête
le triangle qui vous réussit si bien
dans les circonscriptions deux films la
muette passy fait ch votre triangle
quatre côtés et monsieur manche non mais
vous savez en lésine pas sur les moyens
dans l'union de la gauche
on n'est pas à une virgule près le puy
alors monsieur mort chez moi il ya une
chose que je remarque c'est la marie de
deux autres je vous parlais de
socialisme à visage humain
oui si ça bouge à écouter il suffit de
vous regarder pour s'apercevoir que
c'est pas pour demain mais ça c'est
encore un autre scandale en utilisant
soit là moi j'avais demandé un débat
pleine démocratie et on se retrouve sur
un ring de boxe avec moi monsieur marché
c'est vous qui avez comme on vient c'est
vous monsieur monsieur c'est plus messi
à la mairie
son témoin zemmamouche et vous messieurs
et par dessus le marché un côté ajoie
écouter alors là je m'excuse de ne pas
laisser passer ça monsieur bart excusez
moi c'est
c'est profondément été cordiale est ce
que moi j'ai parlé des aventures du
petit éléphant qui amuse tant les petits
enfants moi j'ai pas attaquer votre
patronyme monsieur baba simon je vous
dit non c'est non je ne dis pas
n'importe quoi
vous êtes le passé et moi je suis
l'actuel c'est vrai d'ailleurs je vous
trouve très punk aux coûteuses soyeux
convenant bien des travailleurs qui
regardent la télé ce n'est pas grossier
c'est très à la mode vous êtes très in
monsieur manque le côté alors vous êtes
vous parlez trop en étranger je ne peux
pas suivre
par conséquent au lieu de faire des
anglais cyclisme vous feriez mieux de
prendre votre carte du parti ou non les
convulsions
mais vous avez tort parce que c'est
encore le meilleur moyen d'avoir un hlm
monsieur bah vous savez quand je reviens
de moscou monsieur morts oui j'ai vu ça
dans l'humanité oui ben j'ai une grosse
bise à vous faire de la part des qui
nous unit bonsoir monsieur